considera la tabla con los valores de la
función fx igual a 3 seno de 5x sobre el
seno de 2x para valores de x cercanos a
0 a partir de la tabla escribe el límite
al cual el límite cuando x tiende a 0 de
3 seno de 5x sobre seno de 2x parece
acercarse aquí tenemos la tabla y nos
estamos aproximando a x por la izquierda
y por la derecha primero veamos qué
sucede cuando nos aproximamos al 0 por
la izquierda es decir valores menores a
0 entonces cuando x es igual a menos 0.1
fx es igual a 7.23 9550 cuando nos
aproximamos al 0 por la izquierda aún
más y x es igual a menos 0.01 fx es
igual a 7.49 73-75 y si nos aproximamos
al 0 aún más por la izquierda cuando x
es igual a menos 0.001
fx es igual a 7.49 99 74 ahora veamos
qué sucede cuando nos aproximamos al 0
pero por la derecha es decir por valores
mayores a 0 cuando x es igual a 0.1 fx
es igual a 7 punto 23 95 50 como puedes
ver este valor coincide exactamente con
éste cuando x es igual a menos 0.1
cuando x es igual a 0.01 nos estamos
aproximando al 0 aún más pero por la
derecha fx es igual a 7.49 73-75 puedes
ver que coincide con este valor y si nos
aproximamos aún más por la derecha
cuando x es igual a 0.001 fx es igual a
7.49 99 74 puedes ver que coincide con
este valor entonces es interesante como
el límite en ambos casos coinciden
parece que cada vez se acerca más a 7.5
así que el límite parece ser 7.5 como
podemos ver lo voy a escribir el límite
parece ser 7.5 y comprobando lo
obtenemos bien ahora para ver qué está
pasando con esta función fx30d 5x sobre
seno de 2x vamos a graficar la entonces
voy a utilizar un programa el cual me
ayuda a graficar
y vamos a graficar esa función entonces
voy a utilizar este programa que me
permite graficar voy a escribir aquí la
función las funciones 3 seno
de 5 x
y todo esto sobre seno de 2x
2x ahí está
entonces voy a definir aquí un rango
para valores de x voy a tomar al menos 3
y el 3 entonces vamos a tomar el rango
entre menos 3 y 3 voy a centrar esto
ahí está
entonces estamos ahí tomando valores
entre menos 3 y 3 están alrededor del 0
así que nos funciona y para valores en y
vamos a tomar algunos valores negativos
vamos a llegar hasta el -2 y en valores
positivos para y podemos ver aquí que
los valores en lleno pasan del 8
entonces sería bueno tomar al 8
vamos a tomar al 8 entonces tomó al 8
arrastro esto hacia abajo
ahí está el 8 y ahora voy a arrastrar
toda esta pantalla hacia abajo para
tomar los valores entre menos 2 y 8 y
ahí quedó perfecto entonces ya tenemos
el rango ahora ya estamos listos para
graficar graphic hemos así que aquí
tenemos la gráfica de la función y
puedes ver que mientras más nos
acercamos al 0 por la izquierda nos
acercamos al 7.5 tal vez aquí no se vea
muy claro así que voy a acercarme aún
más voy a bajar esto
y nos acercamos más
acercar aún más para alcanzar a ver el
7.5 ahí está perfecto entonces aquí
vemos que mientras más nos aproximamos
al 0 por la izquierda nos acercamos más
al 7.5 y mientras nos aproximamos más al
0 por la derecha también nos estamos
aproximando al 7.5 ahora la función está
definida en el 7.5 pero queda claro que
mientras te aproximas al 0 por ambos
lados te estás aproximando al 7.5